This thing got over 20 million views in
two days just on this Tik Tok. Not to
mention every other person that's
uploading it just like I am right here
and reacting to it. So yeah, 20, if you
can see it right there, 20.3 million
views on Tik Tok.
>> And just check this out.
>> Nice deep breath.
>> Yeah,
>> you're okay. I'm sorry.
>> Why?
>> I'm a bad kid.
>> No, you're not.
>> You're not a bad kid.
>> Trouble.
>> Okay. I I've seen multiple famous
YouTubers, Christian YouTubers talk
about this clip. Now, three of them.
Nick Jones, uh, Marcus Rogers, Isaiah
Salvar,
and
I'm mind-blown. I'm mind-b blown at
their take on this because they all said
the same thing. They said, "There's no
doubt in my mind. This is a,000% a
vision from God, a vision from the
Lord." I'm going to see if we can hear
him saying that here.
>> So, he clearly, his mom's sitting next
to him. He clearly is not seeing his
mom. He's having an openeyed vision it
looks like. And even in the comments
people are like this is not anesthesia.
This is not this doesn't happen. I would
look at this first comment. I worked in
OR at the children's hospital. This is
not a common thing. So just wow.
>> So first off just because something's
not common doesn't mean it doesn't
happen at all. Uh let's listen.
>> Hi Jesus.
>> Wow.
You're so beautiful.
[Music]
>> He's in a dream. He's dreaming.
>> Too bad.
>> See, why are the people in the room
saying dreaming? He's dreaming. Why
would he be dreaming if he's wide awake?
Clearly, he is on anesthesia. He's on
some kind of pharmaceutical drugs or the
nurses in the hospital room would not be
saying dreaming. He's dreaming. You
don't dream when you're wide awake with
your eyes open unless you're on some
kind of drugs, right? Have you ever seen
videos of people had their teeth pulled
in the car? They're talking about all
kinds of crazy stuff on the drive home.
Crazy stuff. That's what's happening
here. Yet Isaiah can't even tell. He
said um in the comments they said this
doesn't happen on anesthesia.
Check this out.
>> The people were saying he's in a dream.
He's dreaming. He's obviously not
dreaming. His eyes are wide open.
>> Obvious not. Obviously not dreaming. his
eyes are wide open. So, answer the
question. How can you dream or be
speaking as if you're dreaming with your
eyes wide open on drugs just like these
people have had their teeth pulled?
>> I want this to shake it.
>> I think your mama will get you some.
>> Yeah.
>> Jesus when you're coming back.
>> Wow.
We need you.
>> I need you.
>> Out of the mouth of babes.
>> So this is this is the problem with
creating theology out of emotions, out
of feelings, out of experiences.
We cannot buy into our experiences. I
don't care how good it feels. I don't
care how loving it feels. I don't care
how uh you experienced it. So, it has to
be true. Satan is a master of disguise.
And it says in revelation that demon
spirits are going to perform lying signs
and wonders and miracle. It says
miracleworking demons will deceive the
world. That the dragon is going to
deceive the world. How is he going to do
it? In the last days, it's going to
happen through spiritualism.
through uh talking to spirits of the
dead who are coming back to tell
humanity you look this is what I
actually meant imagine if Paul imagine
if somebody didn't see his dad but he
saw Paul and Paul said my letters really
meant to say this I didn't mean you
needed to keep the Sabbath I didn't mean
that we needed to obey God look you just
love and just be a good person and we
all get to make it to the kingdom this
is the type of deception that comes with
not believing. Thus sayaeth the Lord
line upon line. Here's another one.
Let's see what he says.
>> And this video I wanted to talk about
it. At first I wasn't going to his title
because you know nowadays everybody's
already made a video about it. You've
probably already
>> Carson's viral vision of Jesus and
father in heaven is demonic and fake.
Many Christians think so. Unfortunately,
I don't see any Christians questioning
this. I don't I'm looking at the I'm
reading the comments. Everyone look this
this is the the original post. I'm
crying my eyes out. That baby scene our
lord balling me and you both girl. I
cried the whole video. Yes, got me too.
He cried out for a hug especially. This
child saw a glimpse of heaven. I promise
you that boy is not dreaming when his
eyes went up and locked into place. I
knew stop. The laughing makes me so mad.
He really is talking to Jesus and they
think this is a joke. Where are the
Christians questioning? I don't see
them. But when I saw this um caption,
when I saw this title for this video, I
thought, "Oh, good. Maybe Marcus Rogers
is actually going to discern the
spirits, is actually going to test this
with scripture line upon line." And when
I watched the video, he didn't do that
at all. When I watched the video, he
said this was a legitimate experience
and he really was seeing Jesus.
>> Seen it a bunch of times. But then,
goodness, like this video really touched
me. It's really bringing people to uh
repentance and people out there really
believe like God don't give us visions
anymore. Let me
>> So his take was any of those Christians
who are saying that this is a demonic
deception. They are just Christians that
don't believe in the power of God. They
don't think that God gives uh prophetic
gifts anymore. That that all those
things were in the past. I have heard of
that and I grew up in the Southern
Baptists or whatever and they think that
all these spiritual gifts were done away
with that God doesn't do miracles or
healings or anything anymore.
And that's not the case here. Marcus
Rogers is saying if you're a Christian
who thinks that this is demonic, you're
one of those people that just think that
God doesn't do supernatural things
anymore. I don't believe that. I believe
God does do supernatural miracles.
That's why I was praying so hard for my
mom's miraculous recovery because I do
believe that God raises the dead, heals
the sick, does all these things. I
believe in spiritual gifts. I believe in
prophecy and all these things. But we
have to test them. Say, we are in a
spiritual war where there is good angels
and bad angels waring for our minds and
trying to twist our beliefs. Satan is
working harder in the church than he is
outside the church. He doesn't have to
work on those who are going to the club
every night. They're drinking every
night. They're uh fornicating, playing
video games all day long. They're done.
They are trapped. He doesn't have to
touch them. He's infiltrating the
church. And he's getting inside in
positions of deacons and pastors. And
he's subtly over the years changing the
word of God and teaching things that are
now being taught in uh theology classes
or uh what's it called? Seminary. Where
they're all teaching that yeah, when you
die, you're not really dead. and uh
there's going to pre-trip rapture. We
don't have to go through that. We're
going to be sucked out of here. None of
this stuff is in the Bible. And yet, the
majority of churches are teaching this
today. How? Because Satan has been in
the church twisting everything of God's
for years. And it's it's Christians like
this right here, Marcus and Isaiah and
Nick Jones, who are not testing an
experience with the word of God. They're
believing the experience. They're
believing the signs and wonders and
miracles, but not testing it to the word
of God. What did uh Nick Jones say?
>> Make sure you make make the nurses go to
heaven. They're so nice to me.
>> Everyone,
my mom is so helpful. She provides for
her family.
She forgives. She
>> So, you see how emotional Nick is
getting while he's watching this? He's b
he's letting his emotions take over.
This is how Satan works through
propaganda, through movies and and
cartoons like Disney. It's all about
follow your heart. Break the rules. The
rules are made out of love. God's laws
are the laws of liberty, the laws of
love. And yet, Satan has made us think
that these laws are bondage. And yet
Jesus said, "All the laws hang on this.
Love God, love your neighbor." How can
that be bondage at all? And yet the
Bible does say, what does it say about
following your heart, following your
emotions? Do not trust the heart. The
heart is desperately wicked, deceitfully
wicked above all things and desperately
wicked. Who can know it? And yet people
are going by their emotions. I had an
experience. It had to be God because it
felt so good. And Satan, he can only
make evil things, right? He can only
make you feel uh fear and and terror,
right? No, talk to a newager. Since
these people have been practicing new
age and rubbing crystals and trying to
open up their chakras and Reiki healing
and all this stuff, they've had the most
peace they've ever had in their whole
life. Meditation, they've had the most
joy and peace and and connected with the
universe and talked to ascended masters,
including Jesus. Is this of God? these
newagers that are talking to Jesus and
have the most peace in their life
because they meditate and practice yoga.
No. So apparently peace and ecstasy and
all these things does not mean that it's
true or of God, right?
And that's what people are getting
wrapped up in. But this is what the
Bible talks about when this boy is
talking to his dead dad. He's talking to
that's what's happening. He's talking to
the dead. What does the Bible say about
talking to the dead? It calls it
necromancy. What does the Bible say
about necromancy? Necromancy is defined
as conjuring of the spirits of the dead
for purposes of magically revealing the
future or influencing the course of
events. In the Bible, necromancy is also
called divination, sorcery, and
spiritism and is forbidden many times in
scripture. Leviticus, Deuteronomy,
Galatians acts as an abomination to God.
Why? Because you're literally talking to
demons, thinking you're talking to the
dead. And that's why God says, "Do not
do it." Because the dead are dead. The
dead are sleeping in the grave. The
Bible says that the dead in Christ will
rise first when he comes. How are they
dead if they're alive? They're dead.
That's the point. It says that those who
sleep in Christ, that many will rise
from the dust of the earth, they're
coming out of the graves.
People are not in heaven right now.
People are not in hell right now. People
are asleep in the grave until Jesus
second coming and the dead in Christ
will rise first. After the thousand
years, the rest of the dead, which are
the wicked, will will be raised to their
judgment. But the dead are dead. And
this is why it's so important to
understand this. And people think, "Oh,
you're trying to cause division." And um
we can just agree to disagree. No, you
can't agree to disagree on truth. That's
exactly what Satan wants. Deception is a
lot of truth, a little bit of error. So,
you can be a self-professed Christian
that reads your Bible every day, goes to
church every week, and still be
deceived. Because if you are
interpreting
one verse out of context, to be absent
from the body is to be present with the
Lord and say, "Look, when I'm dead, I go
to heaven right away." Well, what about
all the 50 verses that say when you're
dead, you're asleep until the
resurrection?
This is why it's so important. If you
guys did not check if you haven't seen
the video, what really happens when you
die, please check that out. There will
be a link in the description. There'll
be a little card at the end of this
video. Watch this. Yes, it's like an
hour long, but it takes a long time to
study the Bible thoroughly, line upon
line, precept upon precept, here, a
little, there a little, by the mouth of
two or three witnesses. You cannot build
doctrines on one or two scriptures that
are probably out of context. We have to
study scripture out thoroughly.
So um it is something that the Lord
speaks very strongly against and is to
be avoided as as much as any evil. The
reason for this is twofold. First,
necromancy is going to involve demons
and opens the one who practices it to
demonic attack. Satan and his demons
seek to destroy you, not to impart to us
truth or wisdom. We are told that our
enemy the devil prowls around like a
roaring lion uh looking for someone to
devour. Second second necromancy does
not rely on the Lord for information.
The Lord who promises to freely give
wisdom to all who ask for it in James
15. This is especially telling because
the Lord always wants to lead us to
truth and life, but demons always want
to lead us to lies and serious damage.
So what happens when you die? There's a
lot of scriptures about this. Daniel
talks about many of those who sleep in
the dust of the earth shall awake. Where
are they at? They're in the dust of the
earth. What are they doing? They're
waking up. Um Ecclesiastes, for the
living know that they shall die, but the
dead know nothing. So why is he talking
to his dead dad if his dad is asleep in
the dust of the earth knowing nothing?
And you guys are thinking, "Come on,
man. This is a kid. He's having a
genuine experience. U he's crying. It's
got to be real. He's crying. No kid
would say these things. No kid even has
the ability to think this way. Um, for
one, this kid is a is in a Christian
home. They're going to church. He's
hearing these types of things all the
time in church. And you can't tell me
that this kid is not doped up. You can't
tell me. They picked him up from a
skateboarding accident, put him in the
hospital, and they're talking about him
waking up, how he's dreaming, and all
this stuff. It's because he is on
something. Now, why is that important?
Because when you
purposefully yourself partake in drugs
or if you just end up in the hospital
and these sorcerers come in and pump you
up with pharmarmacia sorcery, then you
are opening yourself up to the spirit
world. There are many experiences of
people who have done Iawaska DMT and
they're having experiences including
talking to Jesus, seeing dead loved
ones. Let's check out what this guy
says.
>> Blown Iawaska and you know at the end of
my rope having this crazy experience and
Jesus showed up and I'm yelling at him
and he's always been around. He's always
there and uh you know I'm not preaching
religion but he was he's always there
and I was yelling at him in this
experience and you know like trying to
get his attention. Jesus, you know
what's the point of all this? What's
like what the point of all this pain and
suffering? like what are we doing here?
The only thing he said to me, he looked
at me after a while and just said it's
the human experience. And I was like,
damn, that's a pretty good answer. Like
we are having this human experience and
and there's love and loss and happiness
and like if everything was always great,
you know, we wouldn't be having such a
an experience.
>> So this guy said he was on Iaska,
which is a mindaltering substance.
People do it at for a supernatural
experience. Atheists, agnostics, all
these people who are seeking for
something who most of the time have
pushed away Christianity because if they
if they accepted Christianity, they
would never be doing this stuff. But
I've heard all kinds of experiences.
people who want um closure on a dead
loved one, they will drink this liquid,
they'll throw up, they'll defecate
everywhere, and then for hours,
sometimes uh minutes, they'll have an
experience where they're in vision.
They're totally out of this world. They
shoot out of their body. They meet God,
and sometimes she is so beautiful.
Sometimes God is a woman, sometimes God
is a man, sometimes they see dead loved
ones, but it's always this experience
that they're having on Iawaska, DMT,
this supernatural spiritual experience
that they're having. Does that mean that
it's of God? So, here we have a boy
who's in a hospital on drugs talking to
his dead dad, which is literally the
definition of necromancy, and he's
seeing what he believes is Jesus. But
why is he even having this experience?
It's because he's been doped up with
something. Revelation talks about
Revelation 18:23 says, "And the light of
the candle shall shine no more at all in
thee, and the voice of the bridegroom
and of the bride shall be heard no more
at all in thee. For thy merchants were
the great men of the earth. For by thy
sorceries were all nations deceived."
When you look up this word sorceries,
this exact word in this exact verse, it
is the Greek word pharmarmacia. And when
you look up this Greek word
pharmarmacia, you will find out it's
where we get the word pharmacy from. How
come when you see when you go to a
pharmaceutical
place, a pharmacy, you will see the
snakes wrapped around the the staff.
That's the kaducus held by the god
Hermes. And it says that he is the guide
of the dead. He's the protector of
liars, thieves, and merchants. That's
why this is sorcery. That's why when you
go to these hospitals and these
sorcerers, like I said, are pumping you
full of drugs, you're going to have
these types of experiences. And not all
the experiences are the same. I've heard
I've heard experiences where an atheist
died. This woman was medically dead and
she said, "I was going towards the light
and it was so beautiful and loving and
it was the most loving thing I ever
felt." And she said, "Does everyone get
to experience this?" And the light said,
"Yes." And I said, "Even Hitler?" And
the light said, "Yes." And she said,
"And now I'm no longer fearful of
death." Because we all will experience
this one day that we're just passing
through that we're all just this energy
life force that just keeps on going and
going and going. And when you die, you
just get to ascend onto something
better. That's what's being that's
what's being believed from these
near-death experiences. And so, you
can't just pick and choose and say,
"Well, I believe his experience, but not
her experience because hers doesn't line
up with my worldview." No, the whole
point is that they're all experiences
induced by pharmaceutical sorcery. And
we can't put our trust in anything
that's an experience or a feeling or an
emotion. We can only put our trust in
thus sayeth the Lord, the word of God.
What does the word of God say that
happens when you die? You're dead.
You're dead until the resurrection of
the judgment. Here's a a video I made
called Can We Trust Near-Death
Experiences? It's on Little Light
Studios. And I want you to listen to
these experiences here. I'm floating up
into the sky and
>> there is an explosion of light and color
and then I was just shot backwards at an
incredible speed. Everything just went
black and I just felt this backwards
momentum while I feel like I'm being
pressed in from all sides.
>> In that void there was a voice and the
voice said, "Hey Quinn, I'm out here
with you too." I was like, "What?" Say,
"Yeah, this is what unconditional love
feels like. Love is the only thing
that's real. I'm the only thing that's
real. You need to go tell everybody
that.
>> And I arrive in this really incredibly
beautiful valley. It was just bright as
anything. It was so vivid cuz the colors
were just spectacular. I'd never seen
anything like it. And outside the house
was my mom and my dog Butch who died
about 10 years ago. And I run up to my
mom and I give her a big hug. I'm like,
"I love you, mom. I miss you." And she's
like, "I love you, too."
And then I can feel myself getting
pulled back into my body. And as I'm
getting pulled, I'm like, "No, no, no."
I remember saying, "No, no, no." And
then it's as though this place is
saturated in meaning and beauty and
significance and love in a way that is
truly impossible to put into words. For
me, there's this subjective feeling that
was just undeniable that this is a
divine realm. I uh I shot out of the
middle of this town and I'm standing on
this street that I don't recognize and
almost the moment that I you know I
start looking around uh a friend of mine
pops into my head. He's a a guy that
used to be in a band used to play guitar
with me a few years ago and cancer took
him a couple years back and the moment
that I thought about him here he comes
walking down the street and he looked
just the same as he used to. This is
more so of a knowing. So I knew what
this voice was. I already knew like I'm
familiar with it. And it was God. It was
the voice of God that spoke to me and
said, "Hey yo, this is unconditional
love. No matter how far you think you've
gone, I'm still right there with you."
So, how do you feel about scientists
saying that these experiences are
nothing but chemical reactions in the
brain and there's no spiritual aspect to
it at all. You may be surprised. I want
to show you the context of these
experiences.
>> Today's video is going to be about
astral projection. In this video, I'm
going to be sharing 10 lessons that I
learned from taking DMT,
dimethylrypamine.
For those of you who may not know, DMT
is one of the most powerful psychedelic
substances that we know of.
>> Today, I just wanted to uh share one of
my most recent projections with you all.
>> Welcome back to That God Power Channel.
This the channel where we're going to
unlock the God power that's laying
dormant inside of you. But first, today
I want to talk about something that was
really special and life-changing for me.
And DMT is what I'm talking about.
Dimethylryptoamine is what it's called.
Every one of those people that you just
heard having an experience saying, "I
went to this place that was a perfect
paradise. I felt love and light and joy
and peace. I even saw my dead mom and my
dead dog and my dead friend. They were
all astral projection
or DMT or Iawaska experiences. This is
not uncommon. This is a common
experience. People take these drugs to
have a spiritual awakening to have they
want to know what is on the other side.
And instead of going to God directly
where he speaks in his word, they go to
a drug that's going to open their mind.
and they have these deceptions. This is
where Satan can enter in. You're giving
him permission to enter in and to give
you a deceptive experience. Somebody in
the chat, somebody in the chat mentioned
that you can sleepwalk with your eyes
open. Yes, you can. But again, that
would be sleeping. So, sleeping, this
kid is either sleeping or on drugs. And
what I'm saying is that his bloodshot
eyes are not him being in a normal
state. He didn't just scrape his knee
and go to the hospital and having this
experience. They were all saying he's
dreaming. He's dreaming. You know, um
he's talking about seeing his mom, too.
And his mom's right there consoling him.
Why is he saying I see my mom and I see,
you know, make the make sure the nurses
go to heaven and all this stuff. This is
a a documentary. I don't recommend
watching it, but it's called Life After
Death. It's free on free with ads on
YouTube. And it says death and back. And
these people are are sharing their
near-death experiences. They all said
they died. Same thing. They saw heaven,
God. They saw dead loved ones. And this
is the the host. And just listen to the
terminology. Listen to how he wraps this
whole movie, this documentary up. The
losing one's identity is something that
actually happened with myself and also
others that I've spoken with. I couldn't
recall my name nor begin to spell it
once I finally recalled it. And this
happened out of the blue, I might add.
So I asked my beings of light as to why
did this happen. I asked my beings of
light. All right. With myself and they
replied, you're starting to embody and
connect directly with your soul. The
person, you're starting to connect with
your soul. What does that even mean? I
mean, it's already a huge misconception
that we are bodies that have a soul
within us or a spirit man, like a a a
ghost clone version of oursel that exit
out at death. But these spirit beings
that he's talking to, spirits of light
or whatever, told him that you're
connecting. You're finally connecting
with your soul. Sona of Craig is only a
particle of your soul. My four guests
have experienced things that I believe
we may have forgotten about. But many
are beginning to remember every day.
Now, the core theme that seems to repeat
itself in this episode was how we
treated others while we were here on
earth. Did we come from a loving
position? No. Rich, poor, smart,
illiterate. It seems to be irrelevant
and make no difference in the afterlife.
But what was important was the love that
we expressed. Now, this life performance
is reflected in our life review. What
really is the life review? To me, it's
an accurate record of how we reacted to
situations in our life. An opportunity
to see where we can improve. I am Craig
McMahon and saying goodbye and that love
is all that matters.
Do you see how deceptive this is? These
experiences that people have, they're
saying love is the answer. Look, the
Beatles said that all you need is love.
And what were they doing? Eastern
mysticism, drugs, tripping out. They had
Alistister Crowley on their CD cover and
they said love is all you need, right?
And it sounds so biblical. Look, that's
what Jesus said. If you fulfill love,
you fulfill the law. And and the law is
love, right?
But what is true biblical love? Love
God. Obey God. Love your neighbor. And
if you're not doing that, then it's not
even true love. So this definition that
we have today where love is love bro you
can love a a child age is only a number
right you you can love the same gender
all these things that is not true love
the truth of love is obeying God because
his commandments hang on love God love
your neighbor and so
these visions these things are going to
start happening more and more this
stuff's been going on around the world
for generations but in America I don't
know it seems like God has kind of had
his hand of protection over us, but that
hand of protection is being removed. And
we're starting to see more and more
deception of a spiritual nature. UFOs
flying in the skies over us. People
having supernatural encounters. People
talking to dead loved ones. And what
does the Bible say? The dead know
nothing. Do not talk to the dead. I
forbid you to talk to the dead because
you're talking to demons. God says,
"Don't fall for this garbage, please." I
know it's emotional. I know it feels
good because it's like, "Yes, now people
are going to have to believe in God.
They're going to have to believe Jesus
because this boy couldn't make this up."
And I do believe that millions of people
are going to start waking up and believe
in Jesus, but it's going to be a false
Jesus. It's going to be an antichrist.
And Satan is going to come on the scene
as a supernatural being portraying to be
Jesus doing lying signs and wonders,
miracleworking demons that are going to
deceive the entire world. And if we buy
into the signs and the miracles and the
wonders, then we are going to be
deceived by the antichrist, by Satan
himself. Remember Jesus is not coming
back. We are going to meet him in the
air. He will set up an eternal perfect
kingdom after he destroys the wicked in
the lake of fire. But he will not touch
the ground before then.
If we see anything like that, we know
it's the false Messiah. Don't buy into
the deception, guys. That's why I had to
make this video. You know, I'm I'm
getting kind of worked up and
passionate about this because I couldn't
believe how many people just did not use
discernment at all when it came to this
video. All they said was, "I'm crying.
This has to be real." If you guys are
blessed by this video, please click a
thumbs up. It really helps it get into
the algorithm. The more interaction this
video gets, a comment that just says,
"Amen." You can disagree, put a thumbs
down. All that stuff helps this video to
go into the algorithm. If you're new to
this channel, please click subscribe so
that you will not miss another video
when they come out. We just reached
9,000 views thanks to you guys or 9,000
subscribers. Thank you guys for helping
us to reach this milestone and we will
see you next time on Candid Truth.